欢迎你学习白泽国际站运营实战系统课
同学们 这一节课 我们来讲一下 关于营销活动的应用 怎么样巧妙的设置
让我们的营销活动能够提升我们的循环转化 获取更多的免费流量
我们的后台是在活动中心 在官方报名 还有折扣营销 优惠券 营销 这些板块
都能够去设置优惠券和参加一些活动
自营销活动一定要设置 但是呢很多人在日常的店铺运营当中
却忽视了这个板块的重要性 没有去把这个板块应用起来
第三个就是日常的活动的一些报名 很可能就是他每周没有去看错过了一些报名
不要小看这些活动 他的流量一般来说都是非常大的
只要是平台推出的活动 他都会在阿里的首页或者是一些账卖
这些站外都会给你拉升一些流量的 阿里会重点的扶持一下这些流量
所以说一定要重视 第四个三月新冒节 九月采购节
这些活动能参加的一定都要参加 能报名的场景 所有的
场次全部都要报名 你不管他是否有流量 反正你先报名 那么你的
得到的权益啊或者是流量的成绩啊都会有所改变
这些活动无论是官方的还是自己设置的都一定要
善于去应用起来 那么接下来我们到后台去看一下他的各项操作
那么我们来看一下后台在活动中心 活动中心里面有官方报名
还有一个就是折扣 营销和优惠券
我们首先来看一下官方报名的 这里就是所有的活动
也就是你满足条件的 行业的都在这里
对于这些活动我们是否能参加呢 那么我们就点进去看一下
他的要求是什么 你看他的要求是什么 特别是这里的要求是最为准确的
你要按照这个要求去看 你是否能参加
以及你参加了之后 如果成功了 那么他在哪些板块去展示
哪些地方可以有得到流量 会获得哪些权益 你按照这种方式去看
然后把你符合条件的产品进行报名就可以了 下一步 然后就按照他的有些
报名是按照整个店铺报名的 也就是报名店铺不需要报名产品
有些活动是只需要报名产品 那么你就要去挑选符合条件的产品去报名
通常我们选择报名的产品都是效果比较好的 而且是我们主推的有优势的产品去报名
如果我们报名的时候 用人那些都是数据差的 或者是效果不佳的产品
那么即使我们报名成功 也很难获得流量 所以一定要重视这个报名的原则思维
我们来看一下这里是所有活动 所有活动的话 这个是行业的 你们行业的
所有活动的话也有很多其他的可以参加的 你看一下哪些你能参加的
这些你就可以去看一下 报名的已经报名的 你要看在这里
哪些报名成功 哪些报名不成功的 都可以在这里看 有些人一报名就不去看是否成功
那如果只有成功了才有资格进入那个活动 才有机会获得流量
并不是说你一报名就能成功的 所以一定要自己去看一下 你看这里
这个活动报名成功了 那么他就就被选中了 直播活动如果你能做的
你都可以去报名 这些都可以按照你自己的需求
到我们所说的这个折扣营销 这个折扣营销的话 比如说我们是高级会员
比如说我们是精品的话 我们去设置一下 我们那些会员
他能够有什么样的折扣 也就是这些符合条件的会员 他能够有什么折扣
这些也要去设置 你要善于把这些应用起来 因为这些活动的都会针对客户去展示的
当客户看到你有活动的 是不是他的好奇心啊 或者是说他采购的欲望就会强烈一点
这样就更加容易去点击你的产品 去更多的了解你这些产品跟你的店铺公司等等一系列的情况
那么你是不是就能够有机会跟这些客户进行一个有效的沟通
这个现实折扣的话 我们可以根据我们的需求去设置折扣 去选我们店铺里面哪些产品
哪些产品能够做折扣 哪些产品是更具有吸引力的 比如说你的引流款 那么你就去设置这些折扣
我们就去设置这些折扣 这里的主要是选择RTS产品才能够去设置折扣
如果是你选择定制的产品 那么是不不允许设置这个折扣的 但是呢你的优惠券是可以设置定制产品的 比如说我们现在到下一个就是优惠券
优惠券的话 我们可以设置的是RTS产品和定制产品都可以设置 我们创建一下 那么这里可以在详评页跟网铺展示
你也可以在直播中使用 如果你直播的时候 那么你就单独创建一个直播的优惠券 你时间有效期是多少
是满折券 满券数量是多少 优惠折扣是多少 他上限
优惠上限是多少 也就是比如说100 那么他无论购买多少 只要他优惠上限达到了100 那么就不再继续优惠
使用门槛 比如说你用1万 比如说使用门槛 大于多少美元可以用
你就按照这种去设置就可以了
特定商品也就是说指定你店铺里面哪些商品可以用这个满折券 哪些不可以用
要么你就选全店 全店的话 那么整个店铺都可以用 无论你是
无论你是定制产品还是RTS产品都可以应用
那么这里就是立即发布创建就可以了 创建了之后他就会马上生效了
但是这个折扣券的话设置的不是马上生效的 它是第二天才生效的
所以说你一定要如果你想明天活动开始 那么你今天就要提前设置好这个折扣营销
设置了这些折扣营销 对我们有什么好处呢 比如说我们来看一下
比如说像这些自营销 如果我们设置了自营销 是不是这个产品
这里就有这些折扣的信息 是不是更加有吸引力
还有另一个就是我们如果设置了优惠券 我们看一下优惠券
比如说我们设置了优惠券 那么这里就会有优惠券 是吧
这产品就有优惠券 因为这个产品已经加入了优惠券这个板块
所以说就会在这里有优惠券 或者是你在这里又有折扣 看到没有
是不是更加具有吸引力 而且当客户领你这个券的时候
那么它是不是可以进到你的店铺
这些是不是都能够增加客户停留
还有另一个就是如果我们在参加了整体的活动
比如说我们看一下首页 我们参加了官方的会采购这个活动
比如说我们参加了这个 那么你报名通过了 是不是他就在这个板块里面
就有很大的流量 这个板块流量是非常大的
所以说只要你的产品有条件 能够参加这个活动 并且通过了报名
那么它的流量一定会有一定的提升的 一定会有可能获得旋盘跟订单的
所以如果你是做RTS店铺的时候 一定要重视这些板块
这些板块都非常非常的重要 有很多人就说我是做定制内店铺的
其实定制内店铺的也可以有部分产品是需要发RTS
做几个常规的链接去专门的报名活动
同时参加一些活动 或者是自己设置一些营销折扣作为引流
这样的话更加有利于我们店铺全面的进行引流
另外一个就是如果我们设置了优惠活动 我们在这个这里
营销客户营销这里 是不是就能够有
优惠券被检锁到 那么我们是不是也可以在这些地方选择 选择你想要营销的客群模板
比如说我就预览一下 你看这些是不是有优惠券 所以说你一定要善于使用这些优惠券
还有另一个就是营销活动 我们来看一下 比如说我圈智能圈客 也就是我们所说的反客营销
你看这里是不是有 如果是你设置了优惠券 是不是就可以
它会自动添加到你的营销卡片里面 当客户看到的信息 然后发现有券的时候是不是会停留
或者是点击一下优惠券看看其他的产品是什么 是不是这样是不是都能够
让客户有更多停留的机会 所以这个板块一定要重视 重视起来 那么这个就是我们所说的官方活动
一定要报名 无论哪个 只要你满足了都要报名 折扣券 优惠券
如果官方没有这些活动的话 那么我们自己搞活动 一定要善于用
可以用于直播间 也可以用于日常的自动的推广 比如说你推广某些产品的时候
许马通话很差 是不是可以搭配一下优惠券或者是折扣券 尝试一下它的效果
这些都是可以的 有很多人觉得它的产品的价格本来就很低了 没有办法设置优惠券
那么那么你如果你想优惠券设置不了 你可以设置折扣券 折扣券的话
最低是我们可以95折或者是9折 这些产品呢 虽然设置优惠券可能会亏本 是吧
那么我们可以在产品详情页里面去把它的尺寸
跟它的重量稍微调整一点点 那么它的整体的物流费用可能就会增加一点点
但是呢 它能够帮你有效的降低你亏损 或者至少你这个产品是不亏本的
那么这个时候 客户看到的物流 其实它没有那么感受那么深的值
如果是它多一点点的物流费用 它是体会不到的 或者是说感受不
没有那么明显区分的 所以这个板块要善于利用起来
特别是在我们的产品详情页中 有折扣券跟没有折扣券的区别是很大的
如果你是做现货的一定要用上 如果是你做定制的 那么你店铺里面的定制产品可以设置
优惠券这些都可以作为一个引流 因为在我们的店铺首页还是可以展示出来的
不然